[Music]
hey guys
it's katie and i love giving challenges
to other tasty producers
so i thought it would be really fun if
we have three tasty producers
make breakfast but at very different
budgets because sometimes when you're
cooking like you got a lot of money and
other times your budget is really tight
so i'm very excited too excited i'm
gonna go drop off money at matt
nichi's and jasmine's house and we're
gonna see how they react
[Music]
i have the envelope from katie i'm very
nervous
she gave me this envelope here that has
my name on it i don't know how much is
in here it could be a lot it could be
very little i'm a little scared that
there's like a dollar in it because i've
made katie do some content stuff that
was
not fun oh the prosciutto i'm not super
nervous i'm kind of down for the
challenge i just really hope i don't get
two dollars
oh hell yes oh i got 10 bucks bro
hell yeah 100 bucks oh this is super
exciting because i thought i was going
to get a dollar so katie
thank you for having mercy on me i
appreciate it suck it jasmine
i just really hope i don't get two
dollars
all right and let's see these rules you
can use two
pantries oh sorry i'm so nervous i can't
read
one you can use two items from your
pantry you can use one item from your
fridge
three salt pepper and olive oil are
freebies honestly
these rules seem pretty fair to me
let's see what i have already and then
we'll see what we can make let's do it
currently going through my fridge it
looks like i have a lot of produce
and what's calling out to me um
are the strawberries they remind me of
this really great breakfast item from
one of my favorite bakeries
i feel like french toast let me grab
this bread and
serve perfect don't have to buy those
things i've got
yogurt hummus cheese eggs
eggs eggs
so i think i got really lucky because
i've got pretty much everything i need
to make french toast i've got
bread i've got syrup and i've got eggs
but to kick it up a notch i'm going to
make this a little bit fancier and use
the tasty.co strawberry cheesecake
french toast recipe
and so i don't have the things that i
need to make for the strawberry
cheesecake part
so let's go to the store and see if i
can get all of that stuff under 10 bucks
okay guys i just got to the store i need
about
seven things and i've got 10 bucks so
let's see what happens
found some croissants but they're 2.99
god guys this is my problem milk is so
freaking expensive but i got like a
little small thing of milk
because i know i don't need a lot just
went to the store i want to show you
what i got
nothing i got nothing i could afford
nothing with this two dollar budget to
go to more stores now i've gotten all of
my
smaller items which comes out to about
52.76
so far which means i have about 50 bucks
for my bigger ticket items
sacrificed a couple of things we
couldn't afford sugar but i got
confectioners sugar
all right we are off to store number
three
finally some stuff i can afford
i had a hundred dollars to spend sorry
jasmine nothing i got nothing let's go
home and
make some breakfast
i am back from the stores and i
am ready to start making my breakfast
let's start
baking alright so to make these budget
friendly strawberry croissants i'm gonna
pop
open my croissant dough roll them up and
start with the
wide side once all those are done i'm
gonna pop those in the oven
for about nine minutes at 375
and make my custard i messed up i
realized that this custard or this
vanilla pudding needs
milk and so i'm cheating i have to use
milk from my fridge and that's two items
from my fridge
maybe she'll let me get away with two
fridge items and one pantry item
she's not gonna let me get away with
that
yay
[Music]
now i'm gonna take my wash strawberries
and cut them into thin slices and get to
assembling
i let the croissants cool and now i'm
gonna use a serrated knife to cut my
croissants
i transferred my custard to a piping bag
and we're just gonna generously fill
each croissant
then we're gonna take those sliced
strawberries and insert them into the
croissants on top of the custard
i love the flavor of the fresh
strawberries with the custard it gets me
every time
finally i'm gonna top them with some
powdered sugar which was my pantry item
and they're done they look really great
for what i had to work with
to be able to make eight strawberry
croissants with two dollars and 26 cents
was a challenge but i only need one for
breakfast
so i think i'd call this owen so let's
give it a try
cheers
nothing can beat the ones from my
favorite bakery but these are really
good especially on a budget
all right so we're making like
strawberry cheesecake french toast we
couldn't
afford sugar but i got confectioner's
sugar we are also skipping vanilla
you know you can do without that flavor
or 10 yes you absolutely can i'm ready
i'm excited let's get to cooking
all right guys this is really sketchy
without the vanilla and without the
like regular sugar let's give it a taste
let's see
[Music]
oh okay like it's actually kind of
tastes like a like cream cheese
cake filling i'm sure it'll taste even
more once we get strawberries in there
i'm just gonna move on we're just gonna
roll with it we got ten dollars this is
what you get for ten dollars
i'm gonna go a little bit thick well i
guess i'm doing two sides so i won't go
that thick
that's how you put something on bread
boom excellent see it looks
pretty much like a cream cheese sandwich
all right let's get this dunked it wants
to add
eggs the cinnamon that we got
from ale store
and a little bit of milk that we got
that was probably a lot of cinnamon i
think i adjusted everything but the
cinnamon
but i like cinnamon so that is okay okay
so we might need another egg in here but
no big deal we've got plenty
still left over in the fridge i'm gonna
add that and then once our egg wash is
done we can dunk
our sandwich in it or i mean does it i
feel like it counts as a sandwich i'm
gonna call it a sandwich oh yeah
that's so hefty that's to be delicious
now let's get this baby
on the stove it's all going to wrist
all on the flake of the wrist looking
that bad
this is a very quick
cook boom nice golden brown
coming out that's gonna be delicious
let's uh top this thing with some
strawberries
all right so this confectioners sugar
this is where it came in handy here we
go
i went for this over taste but it
actually tasted pretty fine inside of
that
some delicious syrup
oh yeah that is where it is at jasmine
and matt
suck it
[Music]
super great i don't think we missed
anything
with the sugar i was hoping that we
wouldn't because everything here is
already pretty sweet you got the syrup
you got the natural sweetness of the
strawberries i think a ten dollar
this was actually like not that
difficult because the ten dollar
breakfast is you know pretty much what
people would spend for ten dollars the
only thing i'm missing is like
a coffee or like a mimosa or something
like that but other than that
great time i am going to be making
blueberry buttermilk pancakes steak
bacon fat fried potatoes
a lobster omelet with gruyere and
cheddar and finally a bloody mary
so let's make some breakfast so to get
started i'm adding my pantry freebie the
all-purpose flour
then sugar salt baking soda and baking
powder
and just whisking all of that until nice
and combined now for the wet ingredients
i'm adding my buttermilk
melted butter and only the yolks at this
point
beat that all together until nice and
combined i'm adding my wet ingredients
to my dry
and mixing it all together very gently i
don't want to overwork
my batter at all it's okay if there's
some stray little clumps of flour here
and there
and now for the remaining egg white just
mix that all together gently
and set aside for 15 to 30 minutes now
the pancake batter is nice and rested
it's time to cook them up i'm cooking
these in a mixture of butter and bacon
fat just to add more of that nice
bacony flavor to everything and i'm
adding some of my blueberries to the top
and this will cook for just a few
minutes until bubbles start to rise on
the top of it and there's nice golden
brown
and give it a flip i'm setting the
finished pancakes aside on a plate and
moving on to
my steak quickly going to generously
coat in salt
and pepper making sure to go around all
those sides leaving it
all touched and i'm letting it rest for
about 30 minutes just the salt can kind
of work its magic
now just time for the potatoes my
intention was to buy duck fat so i could
make duck fat potatoes i could only find
bacon fat so that's what i'm using some
chopped rosemary
a bit of garlic and finally some black
pepper and i'm going to cook this over
medium heat for a couple minutes until
my
bacon fat starts bubbling and the garlic
turns a nice
golden brown i've gone ahead and boiled
my potatoes until they're nice
and fork tender and then gave the pot a
good shake so that the outside's got a
nice
shaggy appearance as you can see here
and to these i am adding back my bacon
fat but i want to strain out all the
bits of garlic and herbs that are in
there because they might burn when
they're in the oven
they're already perfectly cooked so hold
on to these don't throw them away
and then these potatoes are going to go
into a 450 degree oven
until they're nice and golden brown in
my trusty cast iron over medium high
heat i'm adding some butter
a little bit more bacon fat and my steak
i just want this to cook for a few
minutes get a nice golden brown sear
on one side i have rosemary and i have
garlic left over so i'm going to throw
those in the pan as well
and just baste with my buttery mixture
that's starting to brown
really really nicely give it a good flip
cook another few minutes on the other
side and then once it's ready
pull it off and let it rest for about 10
to 15 minutes
now it's time for the lobster omelette
again i'm cooking it in a mixture of
butter and bacon fat just going to cook
it meat side down at first
until it's cooked through have a nice
char then i'm going to flip repeat
with the underside and then flip onto
the sides keep doing this until the
lobster tail has completely cooked
through
then i'm going to remove the meat chop
it up and it'll be ready for my omelette
for the egg portion of this omelet
i'm also adding just a little bit of
water and finally some salt beat it all
together until
nice and incorporated and this is going
to rest for about
10 minutes while the salt works its
magic on the eggs
i'm melting some butter over medium
medium-high heat it should start to foam
brown a little on the bottom add the egg
as the egg
cooks push it into nice curds shaking it
around making sure
every little bit is covered today i'm
topping with a combination of cheddar
gruyere now time for my lobster meat all
around
turn off my heat cover and let sit for
about a minute just so the residual heat
continues to cook the omelet and melt
all my cheese
and using my spatula i'm just going to
gently fold this
over that's the perfect lobster gruyere
cheddar omelet in my opinion it's now
time for my favorite of all the
alcoholic breakfast drinks
the bloody mary first thing to go in is
my tomato juice a good glug
of worcestershire sauce squeeze of lime
shake a celery salt
shake the garlic salt and finally a nice
pour of my vodka
oh and of course my black pepper give
that all a good stir
to finish i'm just going to throw in my
one piece
of celery okay so that took a while it
took a couple hours
worth of work but my breakfast is
finally done
everything went pretty smoothly i think
the red flags that i had were
syrup i didn't buy syrup it wasn't in my
budget i couldn't take it from my pantry
so i just threw together a really simple
syrup with sugar water my leftover
blueberries it's time for me to taste
everything
i want to start with first i am going to
start with the steak
steak is really simple salt pepper
get it nice and brown ooh that's good
this is my lobster gruyere cheddar
omelette
it's good i think the gruyere works
really really well with the lobster
let's give these potatoes a shot
and i am like shocked by how brown these
are
the inside is perfectly fluffy it's like
biting into like a mashed potato bite
then outside is so crunchy like i don't
know if you can hear this
so let's try our blueberry pancakes
making the simple syrup with blueberry
really saved this at the end because if
this didn't have any sweet
sugary syrupy goodness on the top of it
it would not be
as delicious as it is finally the bloody
mary
i don't love that overall this was a
super fun challenge i feel like i had to
kind of
problem solve a little bit more at the
grocery store to make my budget work
it also taught me that you don't need to
spend the most money to make the best
breakfast
this is good but i would have been okay
with just a fraction of what i have here
and you know what that's fine some days
you're able to splurge some days you
can't
let us know which breakfast you like
best in the comments below and until
next time
take care friends oh yes
you